hi everyone
thanks for joining us today we're going
to be talking about cloud native
development
in the ide with cloud code i'm sarah i'm
a user experience researcher on google
cloud
and i'm ivan and i'm a software engineer
on cloud field team
and today we're going to talk to you
about cloud native development
we'll introduce cloud code our plugin
for visual studio code and jetbrains
ides
a bond's going to demo some great
kubernetes and cloud run workflows
using cloud code we'll talk about some
additional cloud code features for you
to explore on your own time
and we'll wrap things up really quickly
so let's get started yvonne
what is cloud native development so when
we talk about cloud native
we can discuss the six major principles
first we build everything as
microservices so instead of big magnetic
application we split into small
microservices we choose
different technologies for those
microsoft we track them separately in
source repositories
and we can scale them granularly second
everything should be code this way we
can track this code we can roll back
this code and see the version of change
this includes source code test code and
automation scripts
third everything now should be built as
containers within a container image you
can include all dependencies and tools
that you need
and focus on code itself and not worry
about system incompatibilities and
dependencies complex
fourth is complete automation since we
split our system into small micro
services complexity went up
and we need to take care of moving
pieces by using continuous integration
system build on each commit make sure
integration runs and all pieces moving
pieces and micro sources
are well tested against each other fifth
is declarative
approach so for gubernators the system
state is complicated
so instead of scripts we write a yaml
where we describe
the state of the system the desired
state in kubernetes drives the system to
that state and takes care of it
and sixth and last scalable system in
kubernetes world
it means you can scale your micro
services running as a single deployment
into multiple replicas in serverless
system it's even more important you pay
for what you use
pay on demands so whenever you have a
request we can burst up
a burst down your deployments and make
sure we can serve your resources
and there are essentially two approaches
for cloud native development
we have kubernetes and serverless and it
really boils down to how much control
you want over the stack
versus how much you want to focus on the
business logic serverless is incredibly
powerful and it lets you focus on the
business logic of your application by
providing a higher level of abstraction
kubernetes on the other hand gives you
higher granularity and control
over the stack implementation and
whichever one you choose we've got you
covered
google provides end-to-end tooling for
both serverless and kubernetes
in this talk we're going to focus on
cloud code so we'll be centering on the
coding part
of this journey so what is cloud code
cloud code is our ide plugin for visual
studio code and jetbrains ides
and our goal with cloud code is to
really make your inner development move
easy
we're going to speed up your development
experience simplify local development
extend the production deployments and
allow you to debug deploy applications
all from in your ide and we understand
that developers have many different
workflows
and cloud code can support you wherever
you are in your journey
whether it's getting started with easy
to use templates migrating your
application to kubernetes
editing an existing cloud run or
kubernetes application
or containerizing your application we've
got you covered with a lot of great
features and resources with cloud code
so let's dive right in and show you how
to use cloud code with your kubernetes
workflows
yvonne is going to show us how to use
cloud code to containerize an
application
deploy to a remote cluster debug a
running application
view resources and stream logs all using
cloud code
in his ide so take it away von
let's use cloud code and intellij idea
to develop and debug
our small javascript springboard
microsource application
on google kubernetes engine cluster
first let's go configure
preferences plugins and make sure we
have cloud code installed
i do have it installed here but if you
don't you can also go to marketplace
type cloud code
and easily find it here in the list
perfect so once we click ok and have it
installed
we can start working without kubernetes
applications an easy way to start
is to click create new project
select one of the quick start templates
that we provide for cloud code
let's select java hello world for the
simple down and click next
for the cluster you can store it in
multiple locations it
is docker hub but most of the time it
depends on the cluster that you use
for google computers engine we're going
to be using a google container image
registry
and that is most of the time will be
properly added for us
so once we enter the name and location
we're ready to go so quick finish but i
also have my configured
project already done so i'll just open
it from here
let's take a look what we have in this
project first let's open the readme file
and let's see what type of project it is
so this could be a simple javascript
application running a simple http server
returning a string
you will be running kubernetes cluster
deployment will contain an application
which will run it as a pod and it will
communicate to the outside world with a
service of type load balancer
description of the kubernetes manifests
are located here and as you can see
cloud code will provide you a very nice
helper text changes or even on
some sort of a linking example if i'm
mistaken here
in that field that god will tell me that
this is not correct type and i'm
expecting an indirect number of replicas
which is correct
so we can use quadco to edit our yaml
files but let's go to the source code
next
so we have a simple springboard
application look at this familiar
annotation and spring boot controller
it just returns hello world has double
exclamation mark
and we're ready to go and deploy to
kubernetes but how do we do it
from our ide let's take a look at the
run configurations
cloud code provided us two run
configuration to work in kubernetes
the first one is running conversions
we'll just build your image and deploy
it to kubernetes cluster
how does it build you can take a look
here and build and deploy settings but
build settings will give you a list of
images we're building in this project
so if you can select an image you can
see that builders currently is cheap
jeep is a plugin for maven
gradle that builds your java images
really fast and really efficient
but we can also select another options
docker file is available in this project
so that's the standard
way of building your images if you want
to maintain you want to write a docker
file
you can do that as you can see we have
this jeep mainly plugin configured and
it's already selected
and we also have build packs blue packs
it's a great way
to build image for your new projects if
you don't create docker file or you
don't want to use jeep or maybe it's not
a java project peel packs for use most
common build systems
detect them and build an optimized image
for you
based on that build system and project
so let's leave the selection as it is
with chip and
how this was run so let's check
development cabinets
the only difference would be this
setting when developing kubernetes we
will automatically rebuild and rerun
your changes the cloud code will check
if you do any changes in the code
in your test code or maybe in your
kubernetes yaml files
automatically rebuilding the image tag
it push it
and make cluster update its workflows
and it's really what we call inner
development load which makes the user
ide
the ultimate tool to iterate the debug
and develop your application
right on your preparatory cluster let's
see if it's going to work this way
let's click run in the meanwhile there's
a two window provided by cloud code
called kubernetes explorer if you open
it
you can see we can easily list our plots
and employments
so let's see here in output it seems
like we already had the image in cache
so it's been bold and
manifests have been deployed cloud code
also provides a very helpful events in
event log
so we can see where we deployed what
context was used
deploy was complete successfully and now
we have this link to open
our application hello world it's the
exclamation mark
perfect we also can use explorer to get
some more information
we can describe we can stream logs if we
don't have the logs available
or we can get terminal copy resource
name or even view remote yaml and
compare it to all existing apps example
if you
choose describe and i'll adjust
deploypod we can see
the statuses events tolerations volumes
conditions and everything we need to
know about how
application is being run on our
kubernetes cluster
okay so but what if i don't like this
exclamation mark
what if i want for exclamation mark
let's do that i ran
four and let's see what's going on it
looks like cloud code was able to detect
this change it
checks the change it peels the image we
can see the mavic build is running
it's successful it tags it pushes the
image
as you can see pods were just updated
all pod was removed and you want to
deploy it
so hopefully the change is now live in
our kubernetes cluster
and it is live we have four exclamation
marks on our
demo page this is amazing so we can
continue
making changes to our code or yaml files
cloud code will listen to those changes
and automatically
build a new image push it to the cluster
and make sure all of our changes
automatically reflected in that cluster
for our inner development group so let's
stop this now
and close these windows the next window
the next thing we can do
is depak so the bug is very useful
and handy tool if we don't know exactly
what's going on we just want to stop at
a certain point and make sure all the
variables all the information is correct
but how do we do that
if we want to do this on our kubernetes
cluster
imagine the microsource is interacting
with each other can we debug maybe
interaction between those metric sources
turns out that we can so we've
completely stopped this session
you can see the development kubernetes
not only allows it to run but
also a debug let's look at the
breakpoint here
and quick debug so now
cloud code we'll call an underlying
scaffold in debug mode
which will convert all of your needed
manifest and entry points to your
application to debug mode
support downloads between them make sure
port forwarding is enabled between a
cluster and your local machine and all
the debug
information is being passed correctly
between the cluster and your ide
so now let's go to the endpoint
application again
hit refresh and as you can see the
breakpoint has just been hit
so now this is not my local machine this
is my java microsoft scope
running all my remote google kubernetes
engine cluster
i can see what's going on what is the
state of application
how do i need to improve it or change it
and what's
happening right there running on the
kubernetes cluster
everything done by cloud code all the
needed changes
so once i'm done i can stop debug
session and stop this
development kubernetes session so to
recap
we can easily support kubernetes
application develop
create an inner development loop update
them on the fly
see the changes in the cluster or even
debug live in our cluster
with cloud code so to recap what we just
saw
ivan used cloud code for quick
containerization of his application
continuous development interactive
debugging
and we saw some great advanced language
features we also saw how you can use our
explorer
as a visual representation of your
kubernetes resources like show you the
status
allow you to access terminal view logs
and view your yaml
so really our goal is to enable
kubernetes development anywhere
and so like we mentioned the beginning
of the talk there are two paths for
cloud native development
so let's get into the second one
serverless
cloud run is our serverless offering it
shortens the path between committing
your code and accessing your application
cloudfront auto scales your application
up or down even to zero
depending on traffic because it's
request aware and you can run any binary
or language because you're deploying
using containers
so really this is modern development any
way you want to do it without the hassle
so let's get right into another demo and
see how cloud code works with cloud run
in this demo von's going to show us
again how to containerize your
application
deploy to gcp view service status and
logs
and debug and develop your service
locally so let's dive right in again
let's develop and debug a serverless
node.js application using cloud code
plugin and vs code ide
as you can see i have just installed
cloud code into my vs code ide
and i'm first thing i see is cloud code
welcome page with some key features and
resources
you can install and find cloud code from
here
from an external marketplace you can
just type cloud code
you can easily find the latest version
of the extension here
great so installed and found it the next
step will be creating our
sample application we'll be creating it
based on a
quick start samples that we provide for
power quotes so we can either use this
button create a cloud run simple up
i use a command palette in command
palette we'll just choose cloud code new
application
say we need a cloud run application and
select node.js cloud run template
then we'll just offer us to enter the
location and name of the project so i'll
just accept it by default
i already created this app so i'm going
to close this welcome page
and open this sample application this
simple application is a simple node.json
let's open index.js
uses express http server handlebars
template
fills the template the necessary
information and renders it
for the roots path so it seems to be
really simple
it also has a docker file to contain
your iso application
so now let's try to deploy it and run it
seriously
on our cloud run
environment so again we call command
palette
cloud code deploy to cloud run without
next command that we need
let's click it here let's check in our
login state
it will list and verify everything
needed for running cloud run
applications is enabled
and list all existing cloud run services
in case you want to deploy another
revision of your service
so my select project is correct and you
can change it here if you want to if you
want to select
another project so let's create a new
service as you can see i have a couple
of other services already and i can
deploy a new revision
which will supersede all the revisions
or i can even split traffic between
existing revisions but now let's just
create a new service
a service will be a container running
service on a cloud run environment
and providing our http requests
and results via the endpoint so the
service name is
pre-generated for us let's make it a
little bit simpler node.js cloud run
we will deploy to cloud run fully
managed offering fully managed cloud run
will take care of pretty much everything
for you to scale up and down
as requests coming make sure you don't
spend too much resources
and make your application running in
truly a serverless fashion another
option is cloud run for andes
if you already have your existing
kubernetes cluster now you can
use it for cloud run as well you will
just need to install
a little bit of additional uh k native
and cloud run infrastructure in there
you can use it as well
the application two options here allow
dedicated
will allow us to access our endpoint
pretty much from anywhere without
allowing
without asking for additional
modification it's usually good for
simple applications like this
but for development and real production
would probably require some notification
they're going definitely set up via gcp
authentication services revision
container image url
uh we'll just leave it like that this
imagery looks good to me
it will just keep our container images
in our gcp project
and finally the build settings we
already have a dockerfile here so we can
use it to build
create the docker but also we have
another builder which is buildbacks
already mentioned in our kubernetes
examples so buildbacks understand
most common build systems for java
node.js go and python
and can help you build an image even if
you don't want to write or maintain your
own docker file
alright it seems like everything is here
is very much sensible defaults to such
sets so let's click deploy
it starts building an application we can
click this button show detail states
get some layers build them
and now deploying
rippling container to our cloud joint
service it lists the project and region
everything was set by defaults and now
it's deployed so it says deploy and
insert 100 of our traffic
and this is our endpoint let's uh
open this and hopefully
it starts our container and now it's
running
with this nice little image perfect
so once we deploy the container and the
endpoint is running
once we close this log window we need to
know the status of application
so if we go here on an extension we'll
find
the cloud code cloud run pane
so we open it it's called cloud run
explorer it lists all services that you
have
in your project the project is listed
here and you can also change it using
this button
but for that projects we have four of
three
different services so that's the one we
just deployed
as you can see green check mark it's
meaning the source is healthy and it's
able to run and serve
zero now serving revisions so we just
deployed one revision but once we
replace it with a newer version
uh the non-serving revisions will go on
the non-serving revision step
for that serving revision we can right
click open its container image
to verify where we keep the image for
that application
we can copy the name of the service or
we can view logs
so once we for example close our
deployment tab and close our output pane
we might want to still review the logs
so we can click here
you can find all the logs this lock
viewer pane
has a lot of filters we can do streaming
logs
as you can see the log just started
we're using port 8080
and we already served some requests
we can use it for other revisions and
other services as well
great so we've done this deployment and
everything seems to be
really simple and easy and truly service
fashion
our application the service gtp traffic
let's just deploy it
and cloud run environment will take care
about scaling up down
servicing it providing a load balancing
and doing everything necessary for it to
work successfully
but what if i'm not sure about how my
application is
behaving itself what if i want to debug
i can of course debug it locally but
it's not exactly the same
because cloud verification is running in
cloud running environments on the
platform
on a google cloud platform and ideally i
would love to debug and understand
the state the status and everything
that's happening inside
of that environment the cloud code got
you covered here
for example maybe i'm not sure that the
correct thing is coping here when i'm
doing templates
but it's only happening in my developer
production environments so what i do
i just call command palette again
and say cloud code debug.com cloud run
emulator cloud one
will provide a mini cube based cloud run
emulator for you
the environment will be very similar to
cloud run running in production clouds
so he will just keep service name
container image url
so we seem slightly different for us so
make sure we use the same
service thing here to just node.js cloud
run container image
is the same build the settings all the
same and configuration name will be
cloud run run and debug locally
and that's pretty much it we'll now have
to click debug button
and as you can see the debug session has
been started
we'll do the dependency checks the mini
cube that will be a base for our cluster
is started in special nodes
we do deployment and builds and
deploying our local
mini kubernetes emulated cluster the
image will run
its very similar environment locally on
your machine so it can debug and
understand its behavior without
having to deploy the production
environment the next step
many languages require you to specify
where exactly
are your sources are for new debug so
for that simple application the source
location is only one up
for more complicated applications with
mainly multiple models
many multiple services you might specify
your source directories
in different locations so here i'm
pretty sure this is correct directory
for source
so when it's all done my service and my
application is deployed
and i have an endpoint now that's a
local endpoint for me
so i'm opening it
so it's loading
all right so the breakpoint has been
just hit so you can see
i have all the information running the
application
in the same similar emulated environment
as if it was running on a
cloud run production instance so i have
all the fields all the information
i can step over i can just run
application and make sure
it's running great so it's still running
i debug it successfully i can add more
features and debug it as well and once
i'm done i disconnect
and stop a debugging session and cloud
code will clean up this emulated
environment for us
and we can then again deploy the next
revision of our service
let's close this come back here so
cloud code allows you to easily deploy
your serverless application right next
to your quotes see the results
see the logs from here understand what
revisions and what traffic split you
have
and then if you want to debug and
understand a problem in your application
in a similar environment to production
one you can use
emulated cloud run environment to debug
and iterate on your application
so to recap what we just saw we saw
again that quick containerization using
cloud code
and more continuous development we also
saw some interactive features for local
debugging
and more advanced language features that
support cloud run
and again great visual representations
of your cloud run resources
using cloud code that allow you to view
the status and logs of your services
so we have a lot of other great cloud
code features that we didn't have time
to show you today that we hope you use
such as our easy authoring assistance
using cloud code
authoring assistance allows you to
easily create and edit configuration
for many gcp services such as kcc acm
cloud build and ansys migrate making it
really easy for you to get started with
gcp services
we also allow you to browse gcp apis
from within your ide
so you can enable an api view the status
and install client libraries
again all within your ide and we have
support for build packs
which is an easy way to secure
production ready container images
no base image or docker file needed
which is a great way for you to quickly
containerize your applications
so we're trying to say is regardless of
where you are in your journey
cloud code has you covered if you're new
to kubernetes or cloud run
you can get started with our easy to use
templates and snippets
and we also have those great visual
representations of your resources
with easy access to terminals logs and
status to make it really easy for you to
get started
with both kubernetes and cloud run if
you're migrating to kubernetes we also
can help you out there
with easy and fast containerization of
your application
and authoring support lets you
seamlessly integrate with gcp services
making it really easy to start taking
advantage of a lot of great gcp services
all from in your ide or maybe you're
familiar and you're already using cloud
run
or kubernetes well we have you covered
there too cloud code can help
make your developer inner loop faster
with interactive debugging
and everything you need right in the ide
including support for tools that you're
already using like helm and customize
so how can you get cloud code when cloud
code is available today in the visual
studio code marketplace
or the jeff brands plug-in repository so
you can go in your favorite ide and
download and install
cloud code right now and we're always
interested in hearing your feedback
we track our issues on github and we're
always looking for future requests bugs
whatever you're experiencing we'd really
like to hear from you we do read them
all and take them very seriously so
please
help us help you and share your comments
and feedback
and thank you again for joining us today
thank you
you